[Music]
little joke
all right you ready
everybody knows that the best way to
learn is contractor
[Music]
you
this is what you wanted
[Music]
aim with your hips before you wanted to
hit just lay your shoulders don't forget
to follow through don't shoot off your
back foot let's kill me again then stop
listening to me
[Music]
all right
let's do it double tap to release and
slip it out again okay twist and release
Whip and release your next whip really
[Applause]
I gotta say you're amazing man we're a
little team me is the teacher who could
still do it you as the student who can
do it just not as good I'm proud of us
is there something you want to say
Peter
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh no not so easy throw it on your own
I can't wait to kill one more Spider-Man
[Music]
is this
what are you doing here
[Music]
we're leaving now
please
you're not starving not today I am
stopping it right now
[Music]
thank you
the real Spider-Man couldn't even beat
me
you took my family
but now I'm gonna make sure you never
see yours again
[Music]
Peter you don't have to stay behind I
can do it it's okay that made up my mind
I'll put the goober in and take over the
beam after you're gone I'll blow it up
good luck guys
[Music]
nice to see you again Peter
goodbye Peter Parker
[Music]
miles Spiderman
you're doing it on command about time
right
you figured it out I love you I am so
proud
kids
oh yeah I forgot about her
[Music]
I promise him no he doesn't
Spider-Man oh hey didn't see you there
wow
okay I'm kind of freaking out right now
I mean you're supposed to be dead
surprise oh okay that's that's a No-No
we don't like this this is fascinating
okay that's my face it's entirely
different Peter Parker okay A little bit
of a gut perhaps from dimensional
warping oh yeah yeah yeah I was way
flatter before I walked
four five four three
what was the rest
okay how old are you because you don't
look a day over 35.
you're not crazy
okay organize your desktop lady
I complete cellular decay
never seen anything like this what are
you going taking the whole thing
and obviously you've been glitching
glitching no why would you even say that
you stay in this Dimension too long your
body's gonna disintegrate do you know
how painful that would be Peter Parker I
don't know I don't know you can't
imagine
a night for one can't wait to watch
[Music]
what did you say your name was Dr Olivia
Octavius
[Music]
my friends actually call me live
my enemies comedy.com
[Music]
Peter
I gotta handle buddy
everything is fine
the moment that I'm losing the fight
all right let me tell you the goodness
we don't need the monitor oh Peter
you didn't tell me you had an invisible
friend
be that fast young man
[Music]
it's proprietary
you turn invisible yeah
okay not gonna turn invisible selecting
a bagel act super normal Spider-Man you
know that's funny I get that a lot
[Music]